so top five of all time would you put
from point-guard small you know shooting
guard off power I'll leave myself out so
I would take no you know cuz I'm gonna
feel that point guard but I take Isaiah
I take Jordan at - I'm gonna take to me
Larry Bird at three who was one I would
take Isaiah Thomas am one yeah Steph
Curry got a lot of work to do sir
so you're Isaiah where he he doesn't
have the resume yeah he only got one
championship right do you think this is
the greatest point guards I will no no
[Laughter]
you got you got to have a full body of
work and so and then I'm gonna take Tim
Duncan as my power for and Kareem
abdul-jabbar as a sinner
you think rimas number one so tell me
what's the biggest difference if Kareem
at his best Shaq against us because my
top five is close to yours except for
one okay Kareem at his best - you're
obviously one to cream at his best
Shaq at his best really tell me why I
mean Shaq was a human specimen yes he
was and I like Shaq but he was no Kareem
abdul-jabbar this man could dominate you
with both hands he they when they have
to change the game because of you
[Laughter]
that's greatness